Steve Mariucci my compadre from NFL
gameday morning back here on the Rich
Eisen show how are you mooch good
morning rich what a weekend we had huh
yawn oh it was quite something and for
the first time ever Steve as I'm sure
you heard championship Sunday all four
teams are one through four in scoring
offenses if we finally reach the point
of offenses win championships Steve well
that's you know it's trendy because we
were talking about just a couple weeks
ago that maybe you know defenses still
win championships you got a great Bears
defense you got a great Ravens defense
doing some things and then all of a
sudden where are they now it's all it's
all about the offenses and I think I
think that's reflected rich in all these
new hirings with the coaches these days
the object Manziel in Denver is the
exception but teams are saying hey we
need to have an offensive minded head
coach and be good for our quarterback to
be wide open score a lot of points
because that's what the trend is right
now and that's where they hit the
league's headed with all the rules so
scoring points is is invokes what's
going through your buddy Andy Reid's
head this morning best you can tell
Steve you know so solid and he's so
steady and and he's anxious you know to
play again
it hosts the first how about that the
first championship game in Kansas City
you know and it's crazy and and you know
he'd love to play those Patriots and the
fan the Patriots are terrific
they had the shootout earlier in the
year 43 to 240 and so you know it's a
rematch that real exciting game where
the Patriots took a huge halftime lead
and then mahomes did his magic in the
second half and got back into that thing
and was one of the great games of the
season well what do you think Reid's
thinking though Steve I mean just
knowing knowing what he's had he's lost
Abella check in his Super Bowl he's lost
to him in the playoff with Alex Smith he
lost to them in a regular season with
Patrick mahomes and he's one win against
them finally to get the ghosts exercise
and get to the Super Bowl what
well seeing everything that you saw
yesterday what do you think he's
thinking beat him a couple times now
with Alex let's remember so in the Alex
is not there anymore but but I think he
feels good about his team in this
matchup III know he respects the heck
out of Bill Belichick and that team but
you know he's had some adversity with
losing some running backs and all of a
sudden Damien Williams has happened a
lot of success and in being very
productive too so I didn't Sammy Watkins
I think I think they just have you know
they got a good they got a good chance
to win this game it's going to be 12
degrees rich 12 degrees and in you think
that that would be home-field advantage
for the Chiefs that certainly looked
like it against the Colts right a dome
team but the Patriots love cold sir I
know they're bringing mother nature with
them they travel with mother nature
sometimes in the playoffs so I think he
likes this cancer it's going to be a
doozy it'll be one for the ages you know
you got the youngest quarterback against
the oldest quarterback and boy I can't
wait yeah it is going to be an in Brady
it was his 40th career start this past
weekend when temperatures at kickoff
we're freezing or below and now here
comes 33 now here comes 41 for him and
he's 41 and if the temperature matches
his uniform number I mean we can go on
and on here it just it doesn't stop with
him it doesn't sit it never he threw for
the most passing yards so far in the
playoffs Tom Brady when he was supposed
to no longer have it how do what did you
see out of this offense that they were
able to torch the Chargers on Sunday
about Steve and how many times are we
going to have a discussion is this it
for them
is this it for Brady and Belichick it's
their last chance you know and they just
keep excelling in the 8th time in a role
in the championship game it's just
incredible I'm in awe of the whole thing
with the Patriots I really am and you
know they do what they can do you know
and when Gronk is not the mark that
we've come to know and love they find
other ways with James White and they'll
and they'll throw it quickly then
they'll throw it short and they'll
complete passes and then they'll run the
ball then they have to
then they'll sustain drives they never
shoot themselves in the foot and they
just get out early their game plan is
excellent with josh mcdaniels and they
got a lot of no-name guys on defense but
they just keep playing great defensive
pressure Philip Rivers was getting hit
man oh my god he probably was packed a
night on the way home in the airplane
and so I just I just think that this
this organization we're gonna never see
a dynasty like this again and I don't
know what it's going to end right in
Sunday but it's it's been it's been as a
former coach I look at it and go I shake
my head how in the heck did they get
this done
year after year game after game like
they do Steve Mariucci here on the Rich
Eisen show
did you see Doug Peterson after the game
welcoming in every single player into
the locker room waiting for every last
did you ever do that Steve I don't
remember doing it quite like that you
know I went around and tried to hit each
guy right you know in the locker room
you know but not but not but that was
that was really something you know
seeing the video of him waiting waiting
for every guy to come in and he's got
that kind of relationship you know and
I've known Doug for a long time he was a
backup quarterback for us and backed up
Brett Favre's and I was coaching there
and he's a good guy good human being
he's a pro you know what he knows how to
win with class and he knows defeat with
class and so that's why that's going to
pay them dividends don't think the
Eagles are going away they had a heck of
a year they have a heck of a roster we
talked about that right their rosters as
good as anybody's and if they're healthy
all year they probably maybe get
home-field advantage that they're that
good so it'll be fun to see if they can
keep that stuff together
and it also is gonna be fun to see what
happens with the quarterback well I've
got to ask you Steve you're not in that
locker room but you see what you you see
and you know what you know and you know
Peterson it's gotta be how can they let
Nick Foles walk out of the building how
do they not think that when smite have a
durability problem they figure out that
at this point in time wences value could
not
be any higher and foals isn't like long
in the tooth himself it is a much better
operation when whence is not there it's
tough it's in that even includes the the
the 11 some odd wins that they had with
whence when he was playing like the MVP
last year Steve well you know what I
mean we can't forget about Carson when
Carson Wentz is healthy he is top six
quarterback in this league and so but
but you mentioned it early you've got to
have a little bit of concern about his
durability in his healthy who's heard a
little bit in college too and so to me
and I said this already I think that
they can keep them together I think that
they can pay for this pitching staff
it's a good problem to have some teams
don't have a quarterback they have to
and so to pay whence is approximately
eight million dollars is on his first
contract and if they have to pay the
twenty million for poles so be it they
don't know how healthy Carson Wentz is
going to be just like they made the
right decision I'm not trading bowls
last year because it's Wednesday it
wasn't ready with that knee early in the
season remember so hey maybe one more
year you keep them both and then trade
you could you could trade either one of
those guys for all for a for a king's
ransom because in the draft this year
there are there are no nick foles or
carson wentz okay no disrespect to any
of the kids coming out but these are
proven guys and big strong stud studly
guys that you can count on this if once
is healthy I try to keep them both right
now I don't know if things I don't know
if they could do that though Steve
because it's a mutual option I mean
foals has to say yes I'll take the 20
million from you as opposed to the 60
million by going somewhere else and
knowing that I'm going to start weeks 1
through 17 and beyond I don't know if he
was going to agree to do something like
that why do they not
he may not rich but he he loves it there
they love him I don't he doesn't seem to
be the kind of guy that you know just
starving for
more money he he thinks he may think
that he I can make twenty million this
year and and backed up or play or not
play or whatever and then get a bigger
contractor year after so you know
there's a certain comfort level yeah
rather than go into a team and get your
brains beat out you know because it's a
bad team making a lot of money he's been
to other teams before and it didn't work
out you know he's been on some bad teams
and he almost quit because he just
didn't like it anymore
so right now you know hey take 20
million and suck it up for a year and
maybe see what happens the year after
and get your big contract if that's in
the in the cards there are other
pitching staffs in the National Football
League they paid more than twenty eight
million dollars with that you know there
are other teams that pay more for the
quarterbacks
what's your first blush prediction for
the NFC title game Rams at New Orleans
Steve oh you know and then the last time
they played that was a doozy tooth deli
for 35 right both quarterbacks are
lighting it up you know what rich one
thing there was no a keep to lead if I
remember correctly right he's working on
the NFL Network set with up right or CJ
Anderson by the way yeah there's some
there's some differences this time and I
mean you know they're gonna need a key
to leave to stop with Michael Thomas now
that guy is really something and so the
Rams become much better on offense with
the addition of the key to leave he was
on did you see that he was on the set he
was with the C bisciotti yeah mm-hmm
yeah and he predicted he predicted these
four teams in the Final Four
well I mean Steve it's that's that's no
crystal ball I mean come on now right
and it's 1 versus 2 1 versus 2 and now
crystal ball with a crystal ball would
be the Rams beating the Patriots in the
Super Bowl that's first of all your pick
why do you think I brought it up Steve I
know a season no no mulligans needed no
mulligans needed on game day mourning my
mulligan on Thanksgiving was Rams and
cheese okay so there was my first one
was awful it was Atlanta in Jay
that's a hell of a breakfast ball you
took there I'm Thanksgiving I'll tell
you that all right so are you going to
jury duty now Steve so listen so
remember the last time I adjure E duty
I am so dedicated to you and your show
yes that I did the show on the phone
from the bathroom stall at the Santa
Clara Supreme Court down here I had to
sneak out of there and I was hoping I
wouldn't get arrested but I thought you
know I did it online and I got excused
for today but I got a call in like in it
new ok Steve well we're we're crossing
our fingers although you're a citizen
you know if needed if needed to be
serving you'll you'll go if calls you
got to do your civic duty once in a
while let's let Steve and and so I'll
show up if they ask me to show up but
and if I have to do a show from the
bathroom I'll do a show from the
bathroom by baby you'd be the greatest
jury foreman ever okay tape your ankles
everybody guilty or not I don't want to
get into what happened but you're the
foreman Oh God you may go deliberate and
look at the film it was like a coaching
meeting it's unbelievable I've saw a
play on it called eleven angry man and
mooch that's the one I saw yeah all
right anyway wish me luck I got a call
in at noon see if I'm going tomorrow all
right good luck mooch good luck thanks
thank all you got that said Steve Mary
Jett Steve Mariucci we'll be on the air
six hours on championship Sunday the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience